reporting
heavy smoking fire coming from the roof
of the residence near the chimney
residence is being evacuated
investigators on the scene today at
rachel ray's home in upstate new york
they're trying to figure out exactly
what sparked this blaze
around 7 30 last night it was originally
called in as
flames on the roof so that gives the
our investigators a good spot to start
and they'll go from there
we're told rachel her husband john and
their dog bella were at home when the
fire broke out
but were able to get out safely the home
located about 200 miles from new york
city
is sacred to rachel she grew up in the
area and considered her time
there her escape this morning rachel
thanked firefighters and said
these are the days we all have to be
grateful for what we have
not what we've lost as far as the damage
well not as bad as you might think
looking at this video
officials say the blaze was mostly
confined to the roof and the second
floor
the kitchen wasn't touched at all so
pretty much the whole first floor is in
good shape
welcome to our home and our studio
i talked to rachel from the kitchen at
that home back in april
in the early weeks of the pandemic we
are home
up in the adirondacks we're piecing
together shows from
my house rachel designed the home's
rustic kitchen herself
which included a pizza oven artwork and
reclaimed wood
the beams in all of the woodwork above
us
is from a collapsed barn and look at
this
rachel's home is so remote firefighters
actually used water from a nearby pond
and
lake to fight the blaze i just stopped
shaking
the tv host herself has been through
some gritty fire training
that's rachel in heavy fire gear
crawling through smoke and fire
for a firefighting segment on her show
back in 2018.
the worst part is going into total black
and having to literally feel your way
the biggest thank you to all again to
our brave firefighters from coast to
coast
yes as for the impact on rachel's
daytime show
well it's currently on summer hiatus the
new season starts next month
and it is possible rachel could be back
in her new york studio by then
you